der einstieg sehr sitzt ja neben in
frage aber sie haben schon angefangen
davon zu erzählen je thema auch für
heute abend ist ja dass die korona
panini auch mit ihrer branche auch mit
ihm selbst gemacht hat ja also ich lese
stellvertretend für die ganze
veranstaltungsbranche und da ist halt
nicht unbedingt nur der künstler wie ich
so richtig der auf der bühne aber auch
bühnentechnik bühnenlicht securities der
brezel verkäufer dass so eine
riesengroße branche die einfach
vernachlässigt worden ist und wir haben
dann keine hilfen bekommen und zum
beispiel habe ich jetzt auch wollen mit
einer meiner kolleginnen telefoniert und
die meinte sie wurden als
scheinselbstständige angezeigt aber sie
konnten zu arbeiten sie hat ja kein
berufsverbot bekommen aber sie konnte ja
nicht arbeiten weil sie in der
bühnentechnik arbeitet und es gab
einfach keine bühne zum aufbauen und da
fand ich war es schon sehr kritisch und
dann hat man halt dann im fernsehen tut
mir leid dass ich das sage aber man hat
dann gesehen der eine kauft sich eine
riesenvilla werden wir alle hier ja uns
ums überleben kämpfen also ich wusste
nicht wie ich meine miete zahlen soll
und ich habe sie wirklich verflucht am
fernsehen und klar ich würde auch gerne
nicht mit ihm tauschen also ich habe
riesen respekt dass die politiker sind
gerade jetzt mit der wirtschaft
gesundheit und auch mit der umwelt das
alles unter einen hut zu kriegen ist
superschwer und deswegen vertrauen der
bürger eben auf politiker und hoffen
dass die unsere besten also bestmöglich
dass auch vertreten aber wir fühlen uns
dann auch leicht verarscht wenn wir dann
so sachen hören wie das nicht der den
deal gemacht der den deal und die werden
alle reiche hier hätte es ist besser für
sie gemacht wenn beispielsweise ein
spitzenpolitiker wir sparen einer
einzimmerwohnung wollen würde nein auf
keinen fall ich meine er verdient alles
was er hat wie es erworben hat es auch
nicht mein ding was mich halt gefreut
hätte wenn wir ein bisschen mehr
sicherheit gehabt hätten ich zum
beispiel wusste also ich hab ne show
geplant am 29 04 und keiner wusste man
hat gesehen in china geht es da los und
man wusste wirklich man hat angst gehabt
und genau am 29 04 ist der lockdown
gekommen ich habe alles verloren die
ganzen ticket ich habe ganze flüge die
ich gebucht habe ich habe keine chance
und dann wusste man nicht wie geht's
weiter und dann hat man immer die
verkauften die gibt aber verschoben die
show wird dann stattfinden aber dann hat
man gesagt im dezember aber man konnte
nicht planen und auch jetzt ich habe im
oktober jetzt meine zwei nächsten shows
und ich hoffe dass sie mich wieder aus
meinen schuldenberg das holen geplant
aber ich weiß ja gar nicht ob die
stattfinden dürfen weil es jetzt wieder
heißt herbst könnte es sein dass sagen
wieder chaos gibt und dann waren auch so
ungerechtigkeiten so möchte ich war in
einer halle wo 1000 leute reinpassen ich
durfte aber nur 50 prozent auslasten
also durfte nur 500 rein während im
fußball aber 20.000 leute waren und dann
dachte ich wieso darf ich nicht 1000
leute meine halle haben wir haben nur
geimpfte und genesen reingelassen wir
haben masken pflicht gehabt wir alle
auflagen erfüllt aber trotzdem haben wir
nur verlust gemacht und es war wirklich
wirklich schwer vielleicht können uns
aber auch eins vielleicht einigen das
virus ist hier das problem also es ist
es geht mir manchmal so ein bisschen
unter dass da ein virus über die welt
gekommen ist
dass das den unterschied gemacht hat das
hat sich in andere länder haben es aber
doch auch hinbekommen schweden zum
beispiel ja
ich bin ja immer ganz also ich wüsste
nicht so viele andere länder als
deutschland in denen ich gerne gewesen
wäre die besten zweieinhalb jahre dann
kommt vielleicht noch schweden manchmal
rufen die demonstranten russland zog
dann sage ich herzlichen glückwunsch
wenn ihr meint dass ihre noten und auch
nur einer dieser dem museum
gekommen ich hab ich habe
demonstrationen erlebt wo ich am ende
nur noch eine frage hatte weil das
gespräch einfach nicht möglich war in
welchem land wird ja eigentlich lieber
und dann rufen tatsächlich leute man
steht ja staunte vor russland aber das
jetzt nicht der punkt der punkt ist dass
das halt ne echt
beschwerliche zeit auf ihn war wegen
eines virus aber wegen der
gesundheitsgefahr die da war und am ende
ging es eher darum damit umzugehen als
gesellschaft jeder einzelne und
natürlich auch als politiker ist alles
richtig gelaufen ein offenkundig nicht
und ich bleibe aber trotzdem dabei das
alles in allem dieses land verglichen
auch mit vielen anderen vergleichs
übrigens auch wirtschaftlich es gibt
nicht so viele länder auf der welt die
in dem umfang haben wirtschaftliche
unterstützung wir euch einen heißen
heran
leute das wird überhaupt nicht abgewogen
also ich meine die schäden die durch
maßnahmen eingetreten sind werden finde
ich nicht fair abgewohnt wird gegen die
opposition sagte dass und die dinge sind
auch teilweise wahnsinnig
widersprüchlichen gewesen habe den
leuten nicht eingelöst zum beispiel die
schulschließung der wir wissen
inzwischen also wenn sie ein
kind haben das psychologische hilfe
braucht dann müssen sie inzwischen ich
weiß nicht jahre glaube ich warten bis
sie einen therapieplatz bekommen die
kinder sind mit ihrer seelischen kraft
am ende viele und das ist eine folge
dieser schulschließungen gewesen man hat
die folge ich mache das niemandem
persönlich zum vorjahr niemandem auch
ihn nicht jeder von uns die situation
war nie dagewesen man hat sich sozusagen
mit zu einem blindenstock durchs dunkel
getastet das wissen wir doch alle aber
man darf auch hinterher nicht schönreden
und so tun als ob alles super gelaufen
wäre und ein bisschen tun sie dass das
was sie mit den schulen da angestellt
haben die länder das ist nicht super
gelaufen die schulschließungen waren ein
großer fehler und wir hoffen alle ich
hab auch einen kleinen sohn wir hoffen
alle dass sich diese barbarische
geschichte dieses schulschließungen
nicht wiederholt jedenfalls nicht
solange es nicht wirklich überzeugende
medizinische gründe dafür gibt
aber wir reden wir eigentlich wollen sie
ja gar nicht darüber reden sind so ins
gespräch gekommen entsprechend
erwarten stein
ist okay ich weiß heute sind
wortgewaltig leser ihre texte
es ist ja nicht so dass du eine eine
einzige dieser entscheidung eine einzige
irgendjemandem leicht gefallen wäre also
ich glaube sie dass da irgendwas von
leicht gereinigt und am ende des tages
ist das ja alles nicht passiert weil
irgendjemand die wahrheit hatte ja
keiner hatte die wahrheit und das eine
abwehr ja weil ich fand auf ihrer seite
so hinterhältig sagen es ist gut
gegangen ich habe ich noch nicht ich bin
ich der letzte also wenn wir sind haben
besser durch die krise haben wir also
alle anderen gesagt habe doch nicht
gesagt dass alles super war ich bin
wirklich der letzte der einfach alles
gesund
hätten sich zwei gegebene 2 plus und so
gut war ich nicht gut das ist ja okay
wenn sie das alle anders sehen ich mache
die erfahrung dass ich bleib dabei
ziemlich viele in diesem land alles in
allem schon finden dass wir gut und
vielleicht besser doch als viele andere
länder auf der welt durch diese schwere
zeit gekommen sind in der gesamtschau es
geht ja im übrigen auch um die frage wie
wirtschaftlich durchgekommen sind neben
anderen stellen durchgekommen sind aber
natürlich ist das und da darf man auch
die augen nicht verschließen
also ich habe sehr früh begonnen auch
mit mit kinder- und jugendärzten
psychiatern auch gespräche zu führen
darüber zu reden wie wir auch da
angebote machen können alles was sie tun
hat immer auch folgen ja und das ist es
ist so dass gesundheit prioritär war
aber nicht absolut an keinem zeitpunkt
absolut kein serie cupid habe ich nie
was von gehalten wegen nicht darum jeden
einzelne infektionen zu vermeiden es
ging darum ein gesundheitssystem vor der
überlastung zu schützen das war der
punkt um den es ging nicht darum jedes
einzelne leben das können sie nämlich
nicht können sie bei keiner krankheit
bei einer infektion bei dem man die tore
nicht macht so und dann ja genau weil
zum beispiel die frage war
nun das wusste das wusste jedenfalls
zudem entscheidungspunkte niemand im
übrigen ich hab mit heiner garg ist ja
nicht so als wenn jetzt die fdp dass ich
hab mit heiner garg als
gesundheitsminister der fdp in schleswig
holstein die dinge genauso gesprochen
wie mit der linken
gesundheitsministerinnen thüring und es
war eine ziemlich einheitliche
einschätzung setzt kann man immer sagen
lage alle 17 falsch aber es war jetzt
nicht irgendwie sozusagen eine eine eine
eine parteipolitische verantwortung
sondern eher eine in der abwägung des
schutzes der freiheit des einzelnen und
der gesundheit auch des einzelnen
anderen aspekten im schutz des neben
sitzenden in der pandemien und das
gesundheitsgeschäft waren sie machen
dass sich das ist die abwägung macht
hier wirklich zu einfach sie haben
natürlich recht diese situation war noch
nie da und am ende des tages
werden in so einer situation auch fehler
gemacht aber ein bisschen mehr
reflektionen wir werden ja morgen den
evaluationsbericht bekommen wäre doch
gut und dann gehts jetzt noch nicht mal
darum ob man weiß wie man mit so einer
pandemie umgeht wie man die abwägung
unterschiedlicher
grundrechte freiheit einschränkung
kindswohl
aber wie viel hat sich geändert seit die
antwort wahrscheinlich in ihrer wir
haben eben sagt vorgabe dass sie sich
wünschen jetzt für für den herbst sie
haben die dann keine planungssicherheit
also eigentlich das habe ich auch schon
vor allem jahr entsprechen was wir
werden alles was so da ist aber alles
hat ist dass wir erstmal evidenzbasiert
vorgehen wollen dem wir sagen wir wollen
die bisherigen corona massnahmen
evaluieren wir bekommen diesen evolution
berichten morgen und wir werden weitere
maßnahmen anhand dieses evolution
berichtes diskutieren in der ampel
unabhängig davon wie jetzt die einzelnen
positionen oder auch zu dem bericht
das haben wir mit der änderung im
infektionsschutzgesetz eine märz einen
hotspot regel aufgesetzt die am ende des
tages eine freiheit für millionen von
menschen bedeutet hätte die kollegen von
herrn spahn aus der union vor allem aber
auch teilweise von den sozialdemokraten
grünen waren eher der auffassung dass
wir in ascha der der bundestagswahlkampf
gesagt mit ihm wird das geht ab dann
gehen ja dass wir im märz april mai noch
im weiteren sinne zweig gehabt hätten
weiter einzelhandel irgendwie passten
hätten betreten können
großveranstaltungen städten durchgeführt
können deshalb alles die fdp in den
verhandlungen durchgesetzt wir haben das
ganze thema impfpflicht debatte die am
ende auch maßgeblich daran oder im
ergebnis dazu geführt dass wir keine
impfpflicht bekommen haben im april
diesen jahres mit einem impfstoff der
doch auf eine ganz andere version
geeichte war weil die mehrheit der fdp
dies verhindert hat wir haben das thema
test bürger tests wir hätten gerne auch
schon im oktober letzten jahres da die
situation verändert hat muss man sagen
dass die vorgängerregierung da haben sie
herr sparen dafür gesorgt dass nicht
genug impfstoff zur verfügung steht im
herbst wenn also die nächste welle
anrollt sodass wir testen mussten zu der
damaligen zeit um ein lagebild zu haben
das wird in diesem herbst anders sein
weil wir uns mit genug impfstoff
bestellung jetzt so bevorratet haben
dass wir die leute mit einer politik mal
gab es eine planungssicherheit ich
glaube schon dass planungssicherheit der
gestaltet da ist dass wir sicherstellen
werden das ist ja die evolution die
jetzt kommt aber auch aus anderen
europäischen ländern dass wir als fdp
sicherlich kein lockdown mehr mitgehen
werden ab jetzt als gerade sie oft
müssen wir uns jetzt noch impfen also
sind sie lange sollte noch vor spanien
die neue variante sind da nicht so da
hat herr sparen da hat herr sparen
natürlich dergestalt recht dass diese
pandemie für uns alle neu ist ich glaube
schon dass es eine sehr gute empfehlung
wäre wenn man sich vor dem herbst noch
einmal impfen lässt mit einem impfstoff
der jetzt an die mutation
angeglichen ist dass wir aber irgendwann
sicherlich in die situation kommen
werden dass auch das nicht mehr nötig
ist wie er neben jetzt ja gerade ich
glaube die bild hat heute sogar irgendwo
die das ungleichgewicht der instanzen im
osten deutschlands zu westdeutschland
herausgearbeitet was gegebenfalls daran
dann hatten wir die nebenwirkungen durch
die impfung ab seite an was aber daran
was aber daran lag dass
viele geimpfte in ostdeutschland bereits
mit corona auch infiziert waren dadurch
also die widerstandsfähigkeit stärker
geworden ist natürlich wird am ende des
tages diese pandemie auslaufen und wir
werden dann sicherlich keine
ständig impfung mehr durchführen dann
sagen sie da gibt es kaiser natürlich
gibt es bei manchen nebenwirkungen ist
bei jedem impfstoffen und es ist
sicherlich auch so dass es hier
vereinzelt stärkere nebenwirkungen
gegeben hat aber immer lägen in der
abwägung dass wir mit dem impfen
hunderttausenden von menschen das leben
gerettet haben und einen milden verlauf
sichergestellt haben das ist die
abwägung das hat der spanier durchaus zu
recht gesagt wo man abwägen muss
zwischen dann einzelfällen auf der einen
seite und dem wohl der gesamten
gesellschaft des ganzen landes und
deswegen ist das impfen nach wie vor
richtig am ende des tages ist auch
richtig dass wir keine impfpflicht haben
aber ich kann nur jedem wärmstens
empfehlen trotz der risiken bestehen
sich impfen zu lassen auch in diesem
herrn meier wir werden sie messen auch
hier bei 48 will an seiner meinung zu
haben sie ihn auftreten können und damit
kommen jetzt ihnen herr martenstein auch
die letzte kohle weiter ersparen das
dritte und letzte wir sind sie
nachkommen
werde auch
glaube ich für herrn spahn eine ganz
einfache gesprächspartner sein der runde
weil ich finde dass wir uns jetzt mal
der zukunft zuwenden sollte nicht dem
was in der vergangenheit gemacht worden
sondern wie es weitergeht